[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wer mich auf instagram
verfolgt der hat schon auf einer
verlobungsfeier diese schön schoko
dessert schalen gesehen und weil sie so
gut bei euch an kamen musste ich sie
jetzt einfach mal ab film und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
zusehen
wir starten mit der untersten schicht
und zwar besteht die aus 140 gramm
butter keksen sowie 70 gramm
geschmolzener butter die butterkekse
verkleinere ich jetzt in meinem mixa ihr
könnt das natürlich auch mit der
nudelholz tüten variante versuchen ich
glaube da muss ich auch nicht viel zu
erklären
einfach die butterkekse in eine tüte tun
und dann mit einem nudelholz so lange
drauf und biss ihr sie so klein kriegt
und dann gebt ihr die butter mit hinzu
und verrührt das nochmal miteinander und
so könnt ihr auch mit den keksen
variieren wenn ihr lieber vollkornkekse
möchte dann nimmt gerne die oder schoko
kekse also da könnt ihr die kiste
beliebig austauschen
und während ich die kekse hier in meiner
schüssel und lehre möchte ich euch noch
was zu den bisher schalen sagen das sind
so genannte ein weg der schalen
allerdings verwende ich sich hier auch
schon das zweite mal ich hab sie einfach
ausgespült und die sind so robust also
ein weg kommt bei mir gar nicht in frage
die benutze ich so lange bis es nicht
mehr geht den produkt link zu diesem
bisher schalen denen suche ich euch raus
und schreibt ihn euch dann in die
infobox außerdem findet ihr dort auch
die genauen mengenangaben also schaut da
auf jeden fall rein
in jeder dieser schale gebe ich ca 2
teelöffel von meinen keks boden erstmal
gebe ich sie locker rein und dann nehme
ich mir jeweils eine der schale und
drückt den boden fest an
hier habe ich mir zu hilfe eine
modernisierung flasche genommen ich
glaube jeder kennt die nimmt einfach das
was ihr da habt und das was dann
zufällig gerade da reinpasst und wenn
dann alle keks böden fertig vorbereitet
wurden geht es weiter mit dem pudding
dafür benötigen wir milchbuck cacau
speisestärke und zucker wie gesagt die
genauen mengenangaben findet ihr unten
in der infobox und ich koche mir jetzt
einen ganz einfachen putting dazu gebe
ich alle zutaten in einen kochtopf und
verhöre sekündchen frei
[Musik]
dadurch das unser bacau jahr sehr stark
enthüllt ist dauert das ein wenig bis
sich das ganze mit der milch verbunden
hat bleibt einfach am ball und
rückständig um und sobald sich das ganze
schön verbunden habt könnt ihr dann auch
den herd einschalten und lasst das ganze
unter ständigem rühren aufkochen
nach wenigen momenten koch der pudding
auch schon auf und deckt ein dass es der
moment in dem mit dem herz wieder
ausschalten und den pudding vom herd
nehmen und der wird jetzt auch sofort
weiterverarbeitet
im noch heißen zustand wird der pudding
jetzt in dieser session gefüllt ich
nehme mir dazu hilfe weder mein
spritzbeutel verbrennt euch bitte nicht
die finger denn da ist wirklich sehr
heiß der pudding und ich lasse auch noch
ein wenig platz denn jetzt geht es
weiter mit der nächsten schicht dafür
benötigen wir puderzucker ba kakao und
schlagsahne und aus dem bereits zutaten
entsteht jetzt noch mal eine richtig
schokoladige creme und schaut mal wie
einfach die zubereitung der schoko creme
ist ist tatsächlich nur alle drei
zutaten miteinander verrühren und dann
habt ihr innerhalb von sekunden eine
leckere schokocreme die habe ich auch in
meinem spritzbeutel umgefüllt vorne die
spitze abgeschnitten und konnte das
ganze ganz schön auf spritzen und mit
einem lotto dekorieren
ich habe mit gedacht rosés würden an der
stelle auch total gut passen oder auch
alles andere nimmt einfach das was sie
am liebsten mögen die schoko des us
könnt ihr auch sehr gut vorbereiten denn
sie sind im kühlschrank bis zu drei tage
haltbar und ihr müsst sie auch nicht
zusätzlich abdecken also keine
frischhaltefolie notwendig
die mengenangaben des rezepts reichen
übrigens für genau 25 dessert schälchen
ihr bekommt 50 bisher schalen in einer
verpackungseinheit ich fand es aber
besser wenn ich euch das rezept für 25
schalen gebe und ihr könnt dann
dementsprechend hoch und runter rechnen
je nachdem wie groß ihre feier ist und
je nachdem wie viel ihr davon machen
möchte und was für mich auch super gut
funktioniert hat waren diese mini einweg
löffel die habe ich dann auch auf der
verlobungsfeier verbände für mich hat
das super perfekt zusammengepasst als ob
sie nur dafür gemacht wurden denn man
hat ja auch nicht immer so viel liebe
steckt da und es hat super funktioniert
alle produkt links und auch die genauen
mengenangaben sowie weitere
informationen findet ihr in der infobox
also schaut da auf jeden fall mal rein
[Musik]
die schoko ist sehr schicken dürfen bei
mir jedenfalls auf keiner feier mehr
fehlen und die zubereitung hat spaß
gemacht war total einfach und das
endergebnis das spricht einfach für sich
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und falls sie jetzt noch
eine inspiration haben möchte das ganze
in weiß mit raffaello kokos und grease
habe ich auch zubereitet auch im sehr
hübschen schälchen klickt doch einfach
auf das video das hier angezeigt wird
und falls ihr kein video mehr verpassen
möchte dann freue ich mich sehr über
euer abo bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]